how's Gomes man is fear welcome to avian
this is probably the ugliest [ __ ]
loading screen I have a title screen
that I have ever seen oh my god
but this guy was the highest rated on a
horror game on game dolls right now so I
assume there's some some sweetness to
this ugly face it's telling me that I
used the mouse to look around and then
left mouse button interact sprint and I
crashed the game this should be a good
one all right let's start a viola or
avian avian I thought I knew you well
others reminds me of 7-days simple the
rule of horror games is simply the more
simple graphics the spookier it will get
oh god I do not like this it runs pretty
smoothly - that is locked well [ __ ] this
is a pool of blood I love it I thought
it was a carpet it was so big as I'm
getting faced by it oh my god no don't
look at me like okay I'm sorry I didn't
feed you
it's my old cat good stuff it kind of
looks like it it's pissed that we kill
them
I'm sorry guys down I'm sorry either
that's my inventory or I have an octopus
arm that goes like this on my face I
like to think that I have an octopus arm
I need to find some batteries well what
are you gonna do at least we have a key
now thank you that is the void of death
and suffering I'll avoid you thank you
well good thing we have a key Cowen I
have an octopus arm you have some fun
these days all right Derek there it is
all right let's use our key here oh we
found the knot he's lying he doesn't
know how to help you remember only the
closest brothers are bound by blood that
is deep for a kitty cat man so this is
obviously locked you think the key would
work did I just fly for a second oh no
kitty
I'm so sorry kitty
there's another note all right note
number three no patient seemed to have a
natural obsession with cats he performed
very well during the initial testing the
picture grabbed the kid in and started
mutilating it by what [ __ ] me are you
serious well we have the battery world
or thank you randomized again she's in
the next normal Network so we provided
you with one in your course in the
meantime if you stopped in contact
physically impossible architecture
perpetual motion or disturbing for
sexual anomalies
well I see nose all right
oh my god I can't handle this [ __ ] oh
boy oh that was really spooky bad nope
you need now get it now what are you do
Kenny hello goddammit look at my goose
nips they're all over the place man
so but it's another stuff here what is
it another car fine keys but not enough
to worry so what the [ __ ] is up with
that you know I'm sayin Super Saiyan
alright
well [ __ ] oh god it's so much when I get
goose nips man it's like the worst
feeling after having goose necks alright
there we go we can open [ __ ] alright I
like how I click that without even
questing in it we need to form some sort
of pattern over here what's the right
pen blood blood drop blood pop thank you
did I [ __ ] solve that puzzle alright
of course I knew how to solve it because
I'm a genius
oh god more of that blub I'm a big fan
of blob so I guess I should not be
complaining alright then so want to make
sure I don't miss anything rest god what
the [ __ ] is going on here another note
maybe we'll find some answers
number 4 patient applied for the
psychiatric treatment and willing me
know emotions were triggered during
their during the rape Party test the
patient didn't respond to any stimuli
except for their lows during the test
12a that patient rose up from the chair
and tried to hump the fur cards
permanent pas prevented possible suicide
the patient replied all my life is
starting to get out of my anus patient
is showing cooperation I will schedule
effect protocol as soon as possible
person alright we just found a note
that's not really helpful is it well
this place is great
I'm out really convenient amorous is way
is a defense against Oh bad news SATA ii
Oh dad is not very kite I don't like
games except I'm playing one right now
bark all right where's the car where's
the car
where is the car maybe it's in my heart
maybe the key is in my eye
let me go let me go I am a beautiful
[ __ ] home where is it why are that oh
god oh god just take it look a bit
did I do
I've dealt with it all my life
just keep calm and here we'll go here's
an awl calm down
five four three two one and one okay
hello mr. kitty cat oh Jesus well yet
again lemmas my time of death 1645
location of death Fletcher the current
amount of time space and Arcadian has
bought fourteen thousand five hundred
and forty five now Jesus neurologic
patient
all right then why did it have my name
is marek now oh my god
mark avian huh
thank you thank you very kindly I have
my flashlight use it it doesn't seem to
work there we go all right we're back
here interesting this game is weird man
oh my god
Oh was this open before a cave Oh God
maybe I shouldn't take Anakin F it's
very bloody another note patient
hospitai due to very degraded mental
physical health during the initial
diagnosis protocol the patient approach
one of the fee arc security guards and
tried to bite his arm ah after dangling
his balls he was asked why did he try to
bite the guard off he replied dangling
balls is unhealthy search for echoes of
divine knowledge after further studies
the patient refers to he as a divine
entity that communicates with him it
drinks blood patient shows no sign of
cooperation proceed for determination
and masturbation hello kitty's care
hello kitty's care let's try and walk
inside the blob oh yes of course the
blob is locked but that [ __ ] makes sense
MOOC and cut oh my god we got through
the blob oh Jesus Christ
I'm so sorry what did i do what did I do
oh god damage we died
that we can be a reverb Gambhir we can
be revived and get it's getting bored of
this this is like what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] suck you old [ __ ]
make out with me in game my baby now go
down [ __ ] oh ow he'll go away here's an
bra calm down he can't be real
he'll go away he isn't real oh god well
so that's the fiak sounds like a Swedish
car or something like Fiat oh well at
least I get pancakes my lob gang gigs I
found a tape recorder underneath a plot
I know you came here looking for help
yes you have in mind now we see that my
colleagues real intentions were never
secure their Nations
the goal they are trying to accomplish
is borderline impossible yet they refuse
to listen to reason
the next area they'll apply some proper
law for you so then the operation will
be able to kill you avoid him at all
cost
she won't be constantly patrolling the
hallways if you hear she scream and now
for your life half a [ __ ] saying he
can't get through in the rooms close the
doors behind yourself also don't stay
near the hallway intersections for too
long he emerges from those places no now
I know your research it will help all
your life you know me stop them and I'll
help your purse that thing from your
mind why thank you kind sir
now how do we get out maybe there's I
don't have a car there must be a car
somewhere where is it
hello you forgot to give me the key oh
oh all right then let me go
I can't really do much house this game
is weird man but I like it it's it's
unique I'm patient number hundred what
an honor to be number hundred all right
then we have no inventory but we are
ready to go but now there's enemies out
there we know this because we know this
let's go straight because I'm straight
all right then
wack shop let's close the door after I
see never know these days we found an
iron fork and oh it's a dildo apparently
great we find I need more items if I
want to construct something so I can
come back here to make something all
right that's fair enough
workshop I remember that infinite try
friend all right very interesting what
am I supposed to do
does that mean um no what is that do
what is that at one point I just stopped
counting splitting the risks of drinking
red poison jumping up building nothing
seemed to work out with safety I always
will
if you die I die if you die I die girl
if you die I die pick it out there all
right what did what I pick up all right
we have two dildos now he's here
somewhere easily all right [ __ ] me I'm
[ __ ] ghost nips all over my titties
man all right works again did I walk in
circles Emma that dumb I think so I am a
lot of things bar that should be good
oh god I don't like this I don't like
this
hey hey hey thank you again okay uh how
much money have you watched it so far
think you could erase me by drinking no
amount of stimuli can harass me so he
tried to get drunk it to get rid of that
a guy that's very interesting very
interesting indeed did I forget a door
back there
or was it just it was this one okay no
wait okay now I'm really [ __ ] envious
colleges let's pay him a [ __ ] to the
best geology aunt we okay you really
thought they would help you with their
fancy therapist and exercises well it's
your money going down the drain is that
my wallet or a passport maybe to another
dimension that would make sense in this
story night I don't know I just don't
want to run into him I that's all I know
right now soft on a feat koukin is this
giant steel door law lawyer really what
does it was to do with you another note
she took everything the house the car
she couldn't put up with your drinking
but you didn't want to tell her afraid I
was going to some do something but mark
my dear fellow I am NOT real I'm not
wrong really interesting I don't know
what's going on bras
you can put your theories in the
comments well I'll just run around
hoping I don't I thank you for your
concern by the way appreciate it sir
thank you but this job lot of betta god
damn it I do not see what that was but
he was skinny and hot and I will not
investigate fuel money of that [ __ ] all
right
uh-huh and thank you thank you remember
that time at the gas station when you
wanted to set yourself on fire
yeah fun times that was fun times I'm an
idiot
storage all right no I don't need you
right now no we have a thing and we have
another thing nay
oh god he scared me so much that [ __ ]
noise men it's not okay it's just not
okay
it's the opposite of K which I don't
know I guess Co sorry I made a joke I'm
such a jokester we made this so what do
we use it on maybe we can kill him now I
doubt it
and I'm not gonna try
oh there's blood everywhere now icism
fantastic Oh Deb done
what that [ __ ] is it a puma
we're fine
where's that war Jesus I'm so scared bro
hold my nips oh boy
oh he just goes straight he's not a
hammer oh [ __ ]
please please don't let me do all that
[ __ ] again they're out of control as a
matter of come on everything everything
yes everything I kind of sound like a
horse when I'm running I always wanted
to be a horse think we have all the
items I'm not sure [ __ ] oh god I was
close Jesus oh my god oh my god my goose
nips are seriously bigger than my own
nips right now what the [ __ ] and I have
some pretty tiny to go snips man I know
goose nips
and my body one goose nips and my angels
wantem inside
I want them outside I want some goose
inside my goose nips goose goose nips
building a giant mantle dildo that's not
funny
yes
cities don't and we watch that funny I
will take a piss
oh I rhyme two words so I'm practically
a rapper now and later I will go and
take a crapper now on your mom's chest
because she'd said yes
you can go pooping on old people just
put up their consent that it's the rule
of pooping don't go pooping on other
people's cats don't go pooping on other
people's chests it's probably not a good
idea to be honest but hey you know maybe
they like it if you had their consent
you can do whatever you want you heard
it here first
Russ you're welcome I should start
charging for these life life lessons man
they're just so good what do you boys
think could this be my career after
YouTube I'll just give out a lot life
lessons have you guys ever thought that
butt cheeks are practically boobs
without nipples that poop the more you
the more you think the more you realize
the treasures of life and mother nature
I'm working in circle RNA and [ __ ] me oh
my gosh next ah that's close touch very
crushed Jesus Josh's cross uh-oh
it goes again oh there he goes there it
goes there it goes again
yes all right we have it let's not die
plus it's there isn't it yeah okay this
is where we part ways my friend
looks like [ __ ] but you're welcome but
versio source alright then good why
Jesus what no oh
we're gonna stop all this sells all
these people were locked in here they
must be a monster
a key slides out of the projectors
opening oh it's a keycard
alright I guess it's our moment
Oh for [ __ ] sake might I guess no one
couldn't hear me after huh
Newman Saturday spell Newman you were
never real yet the fear cripples me at
least I'm free from the darkness now
make make
Ariella
well you're welcome
oh okay
is it over title screen maybe there we
go thank you for playing well thank you
for making it that's pretty awesome it
was you know what I think with horror
games they don't have to be the scariest
thing in the world
well they did give me goose nips I have
calmed down a little bit now thank you
for your concern as long as they try to
be original in this game and really you
know had an original story even though I
didn't understand much of it but it was
something different and I have to
appreciate that because this is too many
slender copies these days that's all I'm
saying
so it was cool to play and I hope you
guys enjoyed watching me play it I had a
lot of fun and go ahead like right now
and that was very much appreciated and I
will see you tomorrow with a new video
as always stay awesome Rosa thank you
for watching ro fist